a man who was part of the USC UCLA
coverage on Fox this weekend good to see
you Bruce Feldman good to be here first
things first though let's talk about
Urban Meyer because he does not he does
not look well he's not he does not I
mean the number of cutaways that we saw
he normally will never cheat you on the
reacts to use the phrase that Reese
Davis always said he's always a good cut
away guy because he's always reacting
adversely or not but there was one
photograph on I want to show it to you
here that I saw over the weekend Ohio
State's going for the tie and he is
during a timeout
he's during a timeout away from the he's
away from the huddle he's not even in
the huddle
she's just bending over at is over his
hips while the Huddle's being discussed
in the plays being discussed the game is
on the line like what's going on he
looks like he's in excruciating pain you
know so a couple things
so we at Ohio State our crew did for Fox
twice the season the first time we had
them they played Indiana there was a
close game and I happen to be right like
around the 15 yard line and urban bumped
into his director of football operations
and he bumped into kalida what everyone
to say and I'm looking right at it it's
a touchdown play and he's on his knees
the headset is off and I was like when I
saw it I was like it didn't look lady
bumped in him that that hard but maybe I
just you know I wasn't expecting to see
it or whatever he told me it was fine
after the game and then our producer had
said yeah there's a lot of shots we had
of him looking in pained throughout the
game and then we had him for Nebraska it
was after they got blown out at Purdue
that a bye week and Urban Meyer was
getting a lot of questions from his
local media about not just his health
issues people knew that he had this
brain cyst but they didn't know really
the severity of it and anything dealing
with the brain you would think I'll get
that sounds pretty severe severe but
also some concerns about you know
everything that happened in the
offseason coming into the season with
Zack Smith and how much support did he
really have from the president of the
school so there was a lot of angst
about it and Urban Meyer you know he
kind of somebody pressed him on will you
be back next year as a head coach and he
said yes it was almost like what else is
he gonna say it that of course then he
got asked a few minutes later well Kirk
Herbstreit says you look anguished and I
think when he heard Kirk Herbstreit
that's somebody I can't just kind of
it's not somebody on a message board
saying it somebody who knows me a little
bit he I kind of rent roast or different
threshold the next day he had a press
conference as he told us later in the
week
because he was getting tired of all the
questions about his health and all these
issues about whether he's gonna come
back and everything so he addressed it
to a certain extent I don't think
anybody knows what's gonna whether he's
gonna come back or not but the pictures
you showed just now and some of the
stuff that a lot of the viewers have
seen and by the way they're playing
Michigan this weekend you don't think
there's gonna be a lot of cameras on him
then you wonder can he continue to coach
if he's if that is how he feels if he
doesn't look good it doesn't look normal
well he's not in the hata when something
on I understand you can designate and
you know some you know diehard Ohio
State fans might look at this photograph
and identify the coaches who were in
there and know that he's maybe delegated
to them or not but I mean he's not even
in the huddle he's ba he's yards away
bent over at his hips like it's really
jarring to see something like that and
and I understand that these games are
important trust me I'm I have already
told they're the you know NFL game day
morning Michele meeting phone call has
been set for what's the middle of the
fourth quarter on Saturday I've already
told him I'm not making that phone call
now I'm not on that phone call I've
already told the everybody who's coming
in for Thanksgiving understand Saturday
morning we are we are stopping
everything okay like ever even that
though if I've got something going on
with my head I'd do something about it
and I'm not sure how much he can do with
it in terms of his had procedures when
you talk to him about what he's how he's
dealing with it from what I understand
it's all it's only made worse by stress
well look at the job he's in might is a
stress chamber especially how he handles
coaching so you sit there and think
about it going okay if it's
stress-related it's starting to feel a
little bit to me like Jerry Kill the old
men
so to echo my god it was a different
health issue right it was seizures and
it was something else related but it's a
high-stress job especially how some of
these coaches operate and so you wonder
if it's brought on my stress and it's
making you feel this way you know taking
time off may be one thing
what's gonna happen when you come back
to the games again it's just gonna
resurface so I don't think anybody
including Urban Meyer knows it knows
what he's gonna do after this season all
right so let's move to the actual X's
and O is the non real life part of this
conversation where Maryland almost as we
heard took out Ohio State Michigan had
its own issues at home against Indiana
but that's a habitual thing but Indiana
definitely showed how how you can score
on this Michigan defense how do you see
this matchup
playing out well you know I do think
Dwayne Haskins is a key piece here now
he had some experience he played against
Michigan game yes he came in he's a
really talented he's the most talented
passer ohio state hat may have ever had
yeah he's certainly much much different
kind of quarterback than what you had
with JT Barron he doesn't run it great
but he can run a little bit but he's not
the most you know it's not built into
the system the way it was with JT
Barrett and with Braxton or certainly go
back to when urban was at at Florida
with Tebow different dynamic they have
good receivers their offensive line
those to me is a big concern and I think
against a Don Brown defense now Michigan
has its own question marks with chase
win of it and that's a great player and
he's not only a great player he is like
he is a catalyst you know we had we had
a game we talked to Pat Fitzgerald after
they played him and he just raved about
that kids like you know people like to
talk motor he goes like it's like almost
crazy you know just like kind of amped
up to beyond just always going you
missed something not just the production
wise but the kind of intensity and how
he ratchets it ratchets it up so I think
you know if Michigan is near full
strength that's gonna be a problem where
you have a drop-back passer and a shaky
offensive line going up against the best
defensive coordinator maybe in college
football right now and a really
aggressive front and it really talented
defense on all three
the flipside is Ohio State's giving up a
ton of big plays
I mean they've given up I think at least
five plays of seventy yards or longer
this season that's worse than the
country that's they only gave up one of
those plays in the previous two years
combined they are really shaky in the
back seven they still have good people
in the big in the up front maybe know
Nick Bose obviously but they still have
they still can get a pressure on you but
I think if Michigan can just kind of
stay in it they're gonna get some big
plays because that's what Ohio State is
not a good tackling team and they've had
a lot of coverage busts and I think Jim
Harbaugh and Shay Patterson is talented
enough where he can exploit it I think
if if there's ever a year Michigan is
gonna go into Columbus this is it I mean
this is a very vulnerable Ohio State
team so Bruce Feldman of the athletic
and and Fox Sports here in the Rich
Eisen show Michigan wins this game and
then beats Northwestern or Ohio State
wins this game and beats Northwestern is
there a chance that Georgia beating
Alabama in the SEC championship game or
the way that Washington State just
dismantled Arizona and they go
undefeated somehow Oklahoma negotiates
the next couple of weeks
is there a way that another one loss
team could leapfrog either one of those
Big Ten teams that I just mentioned to
you I think the only way realistically
for that to happen is if Alabama somehow
loses because if not it'll are burn
before losing to Georgia or or to
Georgia you don't hold on to my eye
Georgia beats Alabama in Alabama it has
just one loss and they lose in the same
manner that Georgia lost to Alabama
let's just say that's the way the SEC
teams played you don't think that you
don't think two SEC teams make it at no
idea so I think that's the only way okay
that that a one loss Big Ten champ
doesn't go now it's not gonna help the
big ten champlain northwestern team that
half on the final ranking is gonna be a
five loss team with no conference no
non-conference wins I mean that does not
look good you're not gonna get a big
push off of that I think the no matter
what happened this week against the
Citadel where Alabama was struggling
into the third quarter
I still think Alabama's the credibility
factor for them in
room with the committee is gonna be so
strong that people are gonna look and go
well it's Georgia we've seen this
matchup you know we'll put they feel
more comfortable putting two teams in I
don't see Washington state I mean
they're gonna if they do beat Washington
their non-conference schedule is
dreadful their one loss I'll being on
the road was against a really bad USC
team and the pac-12 is so down I don't
think it's gonna help them at 12 in one
I think Oklahoma if they go 12 and one I
think they would have probably the the
next best shot but I still don't see it
either and then you know you look it at
some other scenarios about you know if
Notre Dame could get upset that that may
be a little more of a wildcard and how
it could affect it I think Michigan's
place is a lot better right now than
Ohio State's is this is people look at
Ohio State they're like number 10
they're kind of just sputtering all over
the place but they're staying you know
they're still only have that one loss
but it is a really bad loss I mean they
were blown out by an unranked Purdue
team that hasn't looked great pretty
much around that either so you know I
think this is cut and dry unless unless
Alabama stops so you're saying that some
of these one-loss teams are hoping to
see northwestern upset somebody in the
big 10 championship game or as you just
pointed out clay Helton and USC beating
Notre Dame here next week is clay Helton
coaching for his job do you think next
week I think that decision has already
been made
here's what here's what I would assume
about this after you lose to cow after
you get run over by UCLA and I think the
stuff and I talked to a former UCLA
player who reached out on Sunday morning
saying I was disgusted by what I saw see
how do you give up 300 plus yards
rushing you can't run the ball and then
it was like they're dancing on the field
at the start of the fourth quarter and
then all sudden they got run over in the
after the fourth quarter it was like
it's all fake swagger and the feeling
there also go back a week earlier when
they lose to Cal Eman Marshall one of
the leaders of their team one of the
best players on the team just has kind
of a meltdown where he's John at the at
the Cal sideline that contributes to
their loss and I think people look at
and go this team has tuned out clay
Helton and it feels to me a lot like the
latter part of the
Rico Carrera at Miami were in the
beginning they liked the stability and
he was an adult in the room but after a
couple of years the message fell flat
you don't know if there was enough
assistance in the room where there's got
to be somebody who people really have a
fear for or just kind of like like a
different energy to balance it and I
don't think there was that energy now
having said all that Lynn Swann and they
you know they meet every Monday has been
very staunch supporter saying he wants
the stability and he wants to give clay
Helton the chance he was he was
determined to keep him but that was
before they lost to UCLA I don't know if
there's going to be a level of pushback
against Lynn Swann gone hey we redid the
Coliseum how are we gonna sell tickets
in 2019 if we're bringing clay Helton
back I mean yeah you want a Rose Bowl
yeah you want a pac-12 title but look at
the record when sand Arnold isn't your
quarterback it doesn't look good and
that's that's gonna be a tough sell for
for USC as they're trying to figure out
where their leadership is coming from
well in terms of loss of the school look
that the Presidency's job is up as well
so there's a lot of moving parts if I
had to give you a guess I'm gonna give
you three names you rank them in order
of possibility of coaching this team
next year clay Helton Jack Del Rio James
Franklin I think you got the three right
there um I would say I would say there's
probably a 30% chance on clay Helton a
40% chance on James Franklin and a 30%
chance on my math right I'm Jack Del Rio
if James Franklin huh here's what I
think if you're James Franklin you are
in a you would go to a division where
you are clearly head and shoulders the
best resource program it's USC and
everybody else in the pac-12 the pac-12
South is a mess you're at Penn State
yeah you grew up in Pennsylvania but
you're in a car in a division with Ohio
State and Michigan realistically you're
not the best of those three resource
wise yeah Penn State has great tradition
but so does Ohio State so does Michigan
by the way Michigan State's in there -
they're not a pushover it's a loaded
division and people can go well you know
how much money can he get us he has a
lot of money and they have not gone
outside the family in a big way James
Franco
one at a place and nobody else has even
thought of winning at Vandy he's done a
really good job at Penn State he's a big
presence I mean a lot of times when USC
is kind of like Chris Peterson is a
fantastic coach Chris Peterson's
personality I don't think even he would
admit this is not a great fit for what
USC wants James Franklin is different I
could see James Franklin as the head
coach there well I mean you and you
talked about the culture change
obviously James Franklin would be that
in the last time USC went outside the
family worked out Pete Carroll it did
but he was like their fifth choice I
mean it's a wild and get to that no have
it all worked out right there I guess
last one for you on this subject when
you mentioned it the loaded division
that James Franklin isn't is there any
conversation that you were hearing at
all Bruce Feldman in the big ten to
reconfigure who's in whipped at what
division I mean it is so absurdly
lopsided and I know that you're hoping
that some other teams and the other
that's a troll you know exactly you know
obviously what northwestern's done
Wisconsin it's a it's a very down year
but ordinarily they Wisconsin would
stand out over there is there any
conversation at all about I think
there's a little bit of chatter I don't
think it's real cuz I mean you had a
little bit of chatter about how they do
the scheduling but uh look the
conference is already kind of reshift
idatz model already once I don't think
they're gonna go in that direction
unless there was a feel like they got
agree they really snubbed by the playoff
committee because of it now let's see
what happens
I mean if Michigan beats you know wins
and goes through and beats northwestern
I don't think it's gonna make a big
difference if Ohio State does and
they're not gonna get a bump off they'll
get a bump off a beat Michigan certainly
but they're not gonna be a big bump off
of of Northwestern you know III still
don't think the Big Ten would make that
move I could be wrong because the crazy
thing is when you look at the other
conferences the pac-12 South is awful
You certainly have a case of the ACC
you're in Clemson's division or you're
fortunately not and then you have the
Big Ten West so it's not like it's only
the Big Ten that has this issue it's
just been disappointing for them that
Wisconsin had a down year and Nebraska
and Purdue as long as they keep you know
Jeff Brohm there are a little bit of
ways away from getting there all right
before I let you go Bruce Feldman some
quick headers for
you you mentioned Jeff Brohm dandaka CH
was the one of ESPN college basketball
fame coverage that said that brahms
going to Louisville is in Brom said
that's not true what do you think it
wouldn't surprise me if he did I mean I
think that was a that's his home that's
not just his home it's like he has his
whole family his two brothers are on his
staff his son is really you know kind of
like a de-facto assistant there I think
that's such a big deal for them to would
be to go there but I give him credit cuz
he really didn't mess with Tennessee
when they were interested in him last
year he wanted stability I think he
knows he's got Purdue going in the right
direction but I think it's gonna be
really hard to say no to Louisville
I think Lincoln Riley another one is
gonna have an opportunity NFL there's no
question in my mind do you think he
takes it I don't think he takes it now
that's my hunch just because he's young
he's got the best ad in college football
and college sports and Joe Castiglione
now he's gonna have to find a new
defensive coordinator that's a big deal
but I think he knows I can make really
make a role run here and he knows the
NFL's gonna be there for him he's still
young he can go for it some other time
and I'm already hearing the Cuyler
Murray's surpassing two in the iseman
Trophy conversation right now because of
to his lack of fourth-quarter play and
he's been banged up and we expected you
remove him from Alabama's team Alabama
still has the same record not the same
for calamari in Oklahoma what do you
think I'm not buying it right now I
might have gardner minshew from
washington state number two I mean
Washington State a team a lot of people
didn't even think would go to a bowl
game has a chance to go 11 and one this
weekend I mean he is the big difference
there but for me two is still number one
of my ballot I think when it comes to
most outstanding player when you talk to
coaches who face them said when two it
is the biggest reason why Alabama is has
the gap is widened wean them and
everybody else in college football when
he's in the game the running backs run
better
the receivers run better routes and the
old line blocks better he's just he he's
so much more talented than anybody else
in Nick saving us at play quarterback in
Tuscaloosa since he's been there it's
it's night and day all right last one
for you the NFL scouts that have reached
out to you or you've talked to them
who's the player they're talking about
the most right now Thanksgiving well you
know what Quintin Williams from Alabama
D lineman who name is start till this
year has really flashed and he has been
kind of
the breakthrough player a couple other
guys keep an eye on Devon white
linebacker from LSU makes tackles all
over the field he's a stud I mean I
think this is gonna be a loaded
defensive line class but Quinn and
Williams to me is the breakout guy I
mean he's just Alabama has had a lot of
terrific defensive linemen but he just a
great technique guy and he's really
really smart and I think that's kind of
loud people because he plays so hard
the latest boast is the one that I'm
hearing about the most still even with
Nick being out for as long as he's yeah
you talk to you know Larry Johnson raved
about him the the long time d-line coach
there Greg Schiano who's been in the NFL
Greg Schiano had told me in the middle
of the year that he's as good a player
has ever been around the only other
player he could compare him to was when
he was of the Bucs he had Gerald McCoy
now they're different kinds of players
he just said he's great against the run
and he's a dominant pass rusher and he
said he's freaky and how he how you have
to double-team him so you know obviously
is coming off injury but I would be
surprised if he's not one of the first
two picks in the draft thanks for coming
in man have a great Thanksgiving you too
my pleasure
Bruce Feldman I love having weather in
person which is best or on the phone at
Bruce Feldman cfb on Twitter Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience